hey I also need to send out a message to
the trumpets do you realize that Donny
boy conned you on the Obamacare repeal
yet very sad very very low-energy
in the wake of Donald Trump and
Republicans suffering this embarrassing
defeat of their bogus replacement to the
Affordable Care Act Donald Trump is just
straight-up lying and blaming anyone he
can I told you earlier in the show that
he blamed Democrats as well as Paul Ryan
at different moments and when speaking
to different people he's just coming up
with anything he can't clutching at
straws to figure out a way to avoid
blame for this he also and they I'm
truly stunned that he would even try to
do this although you know given what
he's tried to lie about I guess I
shouldn't be that surprised
we all know pat that Trump has been
promising for close to two years now an
immediate repeal of Obamacare an
immediate repeal of Obamacare and when
the bill was pulled on Friday Donald
Trump tried to say immediate repeal I'd
heard him I don't remember anything
about an immediate repeal here's Donald
four days
I never said repeal and replace
Obamacare you've all heard my speeches I
never said repeal it and replace it with
in 64 days a long time oh I mean it's
truly cringe-worthy let's look at some
of trumps promises on Obamacare and this
is the the left-wingers notice this is
for the trumpets okay you got played by
this orange clown let's look at tweet
number one here we will immediately
repair repeal and replace Obamacare and
nobody can do that like me we will save
money and have much better health care
that is from what was the data on that
one Pat that is from February of 2016
right over a year ago
in March of 2016 on his campaign website
Trump said on day one of the Trump
administration we will ask Congress to
immediately deliver a full repeal of
Obamacare that page has since been
deleted from Donald Trump's website and
also by the way these incidents with
Donald Trump and his promises Obamacare
is going to be repealed and replaced
Obamacare yo yeah we're gonna have a
strong country again and Obamacare has
to go we can't afford it it's no good
you're gonna end up with great health
care for a fraction of the price and
that's gonna take place immediately
after we go in okay
immediately right quick at this point
only his most ardent supporters could
possibly believe this BS right I would
have to imagine it seems like the Trump
administration by now that realized that
health care is a difficult topic
yeah it's 18 percent of the economy so
you mean to try to just push a bill
through in three weeks that's obviously
not going to be something that works
Obamacare was actually debated for over
a year
they were had to make concessions and
there was things that went wrong with it
they had to pull the public option for
example but what by the time they got
the bill to the floor it had been
debated and thoroughly considered not
even realistic I mean it was never
realistic to begin with which is why the
Trump supporters should have known they
were being lied to even more and more
foxnews contributors and commentators or
even saying yeah this is a failure and
Trump is lying by the way as this
disaster was unfolding what did Donald
Trump have time for well we're showing
this to our video audience Donald Trump
had time to climb into a big rig and
pretend to drive a huge truck honking
the horn at one point wait for it the
President of the US there it is the
President of the United States ladies
and gentlemen seriously
we might be wrong that the president
actually has to do stuff there's
probably people Pat who would rather see
Trump just honk a horn in a truck than
actually pass legislation I liked it I
was happy to see him do that maybe he's
better off there than inside the Oval
Office he's probably gonna do less
damage honking the horn on a truck I
mean it we're dealing with a little kid
here right this is a man-child who is
interested in just honking horns on
trucks when we have just an embarrassing
debacle of legislation many many
discussions about this failure of the
aah a on our reddit discussion forum and
hope you'll join us there david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT zip
recruiter sponsoring today's program if
you are hiring it's really important to
have the greatest pool of candidates to
choose from and posting your job in one
place really just isn't enough if you
want to find the perfect hire you should
post your job to all the top job sites
and now you can with zip recruiter zip
recruiter allows you to post to 200 plus
job sites including social media
networks including Facebook and Twitter
with one-click their website also shows
you trending career field cities
searches you can filter candidates by
city or industry nationwide just post
once and watch your qualified candidates
roll in no juggling emails or calls to
the office and if you do run into issues
you have a friendly and importantly
human support staff at zip recruiter
ready to help right now my listeners and
viewers can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free by going to zip recruiter
dot-com forward slash free trial zip
recruiter dot-com slash free trial one
more time try zip recruiter free @ zip
recruiter forward slash free trial